This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个爱心播客。保证真人。百分之二。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目“2%”中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养坚韧精神、健身意识以及抗压能力的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些磨难，你将会以一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的姿态破茧成重生。收听“2%”。也就是数字2。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back at it》播客中。从1979年开始，对当时的我是个大日子。84年对我来说也很大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利士。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着去理解我们是如何挺过来的。与我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜爱的作家一起。就像马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代那样。84年是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我认为没有哪个年份对黑人来说更重要了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯。这个空间专门探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方绝对不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人穿着一套精神铠甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就必须这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA电台应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Learn the Hard Way。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下一对双胞胎。但这次怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批互联网侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个同性恋者。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这就是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你的二十岁心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时面临的一些重大生活变化与转型及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s.
对于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎回到本播客。新听友、老听友，无论你身处世界的哪个角落。很高兴你能回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将继续剖析二十岁的心理学。
I've been having this huge desire recently to see what it is like to go without my phone for a week, for a month, maybe forever. And I'm not talking about a digital detox, although that would probably be nice at this point, I am talking about a full breakup, a full intervention, a full divorce between me and my iPhone because I've been tracking so much of my unhappiness
我最近产生了一种强烈的渴望，想看看如果一个星期、一个月、甚至永远没有手机会是什么样。我指的不是数字排毒，尽管到了这个时候那可能也不错，我指的是彻底分手，进行一次全方位的干预，我和我的iPhone之间来一次彻底的离婚，因为我一直在追溯，发现我的很多不快乐
back to this device that has become ubiquitous in all our lives. And what it's been doing to my mind and to my productivity, into my relationships, into my self-esteem, we are probably never more than five meters away from our phone at any given time. We take it to the bathroom, even if people think that's gross. A lot of us do. We spend more time with it than our friends and our own parents.
都归咎于这个在我们所有人生活中无处不在的设备。以及它对我的大脑、我的生产力、我的人际关系以及我的自尊所做的一切，我们在任何特定时刻距离手机大概都不会超过五米。我们把它带进洗手间，即使人们觉得这很恶心。我们很多人都这样做。我们花在它上面的时间比陪朋友和亲生父母的时间还要多。
It is this constant force in our lives. So why aren't we examining our relationship with it more? What's really caused me to start thinking about this was not one. It was actually two things. two things I came across recently. One was a quote. One was an article. The quote was from Henry David Thruh, and it essentially said,
它成了我们生活中持续存在的一种力量。那么，为什么我们没有更多地审视我们与它的关系呢？真正让我开始思考这件事的原因不止一个。实际上是两个。我最近遇到的两件事。一个是名言。一篇是文章。这句名言出自亨利·大卫·梭罗，它的大意是，
the cost of anything is the amount of life you exchange for it. And ironically, it came across my Instagram feed and just kind of reached through the screen and grabbed me. And my brain immediately was like, oh, this is talking about your phone. and the habits that you currently have with this device and how much life or time I'm giving to scrolling and to apps and to social media for very, very little reward. It is like a pit that I am sinking so much of my day into, almost six hours a day at this point, which is like honestly a bit disgusting when I say it out loud.
任何事物的成本，都是你为了它而付出的生命的代价。具有讽刺意味的是，它出现在我的Instagram信息流中，就好像穿透屏幕抓住了我。我的大脑立刻反应过来，哦，这说的不就是你的手机吗。以及你目前对这个设备的习惯，为了极少极少的回报，我在刷屏幕、刷应用、刷社交媒体上付出了多少生命或时间。这就像是一个无底洞，我把一天中大部分时间都陷在里面，此时此刻几乎占了六天中的六个小时，老实说，当我大声说出来时，这感觉有点恶心。
And in actuality, for how much time I am spending on this thing, I'm getting basically nothing from it. And that time would so much be better spent learning a new skill or experiencing the world or being present with my friends. So that quote really just kind of gripped me and has been running through my head a lot recently. The second thing that has me thinking me and my phone need to get some serious distance was an article written by the ABC that I read about a group of teenagers who call themselves the Luddite club. Luddites, I only just learnt this, is the name of a group of text.
实际上，我花在这东西上的时间那么多，却几乎什么也没得到。把这些时间花在学习一项新技能、体验世界或者陪伴朋友身上，要好得多。所以那句话真的深深地触动了我，最近一直在我的脑海里盘旋。第二件让我觉得我和我的手机必须保持严重距离的事情，是我读到ABC（澳大利亚广播公司）写的一篇文章，讲的是一群自称“勒德分子俱乐部”的青少年。我刚了解到，“勒德分子”是一群纺织工人的名字，
workers who during the Industrial Revolution refused to use machinery. They like actively destroyed machinery like they were anti-technology. These kids, the Luddites, they don't have smartphones. Some of them have never had a smartphone. They don't use social media. They have what they call dumb phones. So basically a flip phone with no apps. It's just for emergencies. And they're kind of this group of individuals who seem so connected. They have all these friends, they seem so much happier, so much more self-expressive and just wise beyond their years. And I was reading this article and I was looking at these kids who have kind of gone against our expectations that they would be quite lonely or disconnected. And I felt very, very envious.
他们在工业革命期间拒绝使用机器。他们积极地破坏机器，就像他们是反科技的一样。这些孩子，也就是“勒德分子”，他们没有智能手机。他们有些人从来没有过智能手机。他们不用社交媒体。他们使用的是他们所谓的笨手机。基本上就是没有应用程序的翻盖手机。只能用来应急。他们似乎是这样一群人，显得如此紧密相连。他们有这么多的朋友，看起来快乐得多，更具自我表达能力，而且超乎年龄的成熟。我当时正在读这篇文章，看着这些违背了我们预期（即他们会感到孤独或脱节）的孩子们，我感到了非常非常的嫉妒。
However, when I also started thinking, like, maybe I could do that, maybe I should do that, the first reaction I had was one of like panic and almost anxiety about the thought of not being, connected and all these situations I might not be able to handle without my iPhone and it just brought me this extreme unease and it made me think any item whose absence creates that's that much of a reaction needs to be rethought because how can an inanimate object control my emotions my self-perception my sense of capability that much how did we kind of let it go this far to the point where a lot of people wouldn't know how to navigate their own city with their phone. They wouldn't know how to get home.
然而，当我同时开始思考，比如，也许我也能做到，也许我也应该这样做时，我的第一反应是一种恐慌，甚至是对无法保持连接的想象感到焦虑，在没有iPhone的情况下我可能无法应对所有这些情况，这给我带来了极大的不安，它让我觉得任何只要缺少了它就会引起如此大反应的物品都需要重新评估，因为一个无生命的物体怎么能如此严重地控制我的情绪、我的自我认知、我的能力感呢，我们怎么会任由事情发展到这一步，以至于很多人如果没有手机，甚至不知道如何在自己的城市里导航。他们不知道怎么回家。
They wouldn't know how to entertain themselves. They wouldn't know how to be connected. It's kind of scary when you really start to interrogate how this technology is actually harming us. And I know I sound like such an old lady. Like I sound like such a concerned parent. But it is what I want to talk about today. I'm in this weird mental headspace of wanting to rethink my technological habits. And I want to see if you guys are feeling the same way.
他们不知道如何娱乐自己。他们不知道如何保持联系。当你真正开始审视这项技术实际上是如何伤害我们时，这有点吓人。我知道我听起来像个老太婆。听起来就像一个过度担忧的家长。但这就是我今天要谈的内容。我正处于一种想要重新思考我的科技习惯的奇怪精神状态中。我想看看你们是否也有同感。
And also how we can find kind of a solution here, because it might not be a full breakup with our smartphones, but there definitely is part of this that we need to rethink. Is there a middle ground or have we just gone too far? What would our brains, what did our brains look like before our smartphones? What do they look like now? What could they look like afterwards? and just so many other questions that I've been having around what this is doing to my mind. So I'm so excited to be able to explore with you guys today.
以及我们如何在这里找到某种解决方案，因为这可能不是与智能手机彻底分手，但其中肯定有一部分需要我们重新思考。是否存在一个中间地带，还是我们已经走得太远了？在智能手机出现之前，我们的大脑是什么样的？它们现在是什么样的？它们以后可能会是什么样的？还有我一直在思考的关于这正在对我的大脑产生什么影响的许许多多其他问题。所以我非常高兴今天能和大家一起探索。
Hopefully give myself some answers, give you guys some answers if you're feeling this too. Without further ado, let's talk about why we should maybe be breaking up with our phones. Stay with us. So other than that thorough quote and that article, there have been a few other kind of wake-up calls for me recently, I would. say. Firstly, it was a conversation I had with my boyfriend where he kind of made like an offhand comment about me always being on my phone and it offended me a little bit. But he said to me afterwards, like, surely you know this about yourself. Surely you know that you're someone who's like always working, always on their phone. Like this is just kind of who you are. And I was taken aback because
希望能给我自己一些答案，也给那些同样有此感受的大家一些答案。废话不多说，让我们来谈谈为什么我们也许应该和手机分手。请留下来。所以除了梭罗的那句话和那篇文章，最近对我来说还有其他几个算是警钟的时刻，我想。首先，是我和男友的一次对话，他漫不经心地评论说我总是抱着手机，这让我觉得有点被冒犯。但他事后对我说，你肯定对自己这点心知肚明吧。你肯定知道自己是个总是工作、总是玩手机的人。这大概就是你的本性。我当时吓了一跳，因为
I did not think that about myself. It was like a major psychological blind spot for me, something that is obvious to others, obviously not to me. And I kind of had chosen, I guess, in some way to ignore that this is how other people perceived me and this is how I behaved. Then after that, I started really going into my screen time data and just realized like, wow, I, this thing is controlling me more than I'm controlling it. Like, I'm picking up my phone 300 times a day, each time I'm on it for like two minutes or more. I'm basically giving up my, life to this inanimate thing in like 1% increments. Social media, I think, like most of us is probably where I spend most of my time.
我并不觉得自已是这样的人。这对我来说是一个重大的心理盲点，对别人来说显而易见的事，对我却显然不是。我想我某种程度上选择去忽视别人是这样看待我的，我也是这样行事的。在那之后，我开始真正查看我的屏幕使用时间数据，然后意识到，哇，我，这个东西控制我的程度超过了我控制它。比如，我一天拿起手机300次，每次都玩两分钟或更长时间。我基本上是在以1%的增量，将我的生命拱手让给这个无生命的玩意儿。我想社交媒体和我们大多数人一样，大概是我花最多时间的地方。
And I think I could largely excuse that because social media is part of my job. And so it was justifiable. But really, I think I could only be on social media for 30 minutes a day or less and still do my job. This was, again, like, just an excuse that I was giving to myself. I guess an excuse to stop me feeling a bit embarrassed or ashamed or alarmed or like to stop me from recognizing that something kind of needed to be done. There's also this realization I had that if someone asked me, someone held a gun to my head and said, tell me the last five things that you saw on Instagram or the last five reels that you scroll past on TikTok,
而且我认为我基本上可以为之开脱，因为社交媒体是我的工作的一部分。所以这是情有可原的。但说实话，我想我每天花在社交媒体上的时间只要30分钟或更少，也照样能完成工作。这，再次只是我在给自己找借口。我想这是一个借口，为了阻止自己感到有点尴尬、羞耻或惊慌，或者阻止自己去认识到有些事情确实需要去做了。我也意识到，如果有人拿枪指着我的头，对我说，说出你最后在Instagram上看到的五样东西，或者你在TikTok上刷过去的最后五个短视频，
I would not be able to tell them. a lot of this scrolling that I was doing and that I still am doing is entirely mindless. And if I wasn't present with the outside world, which I wasn't because I was on my phone, and I obviously wasn't present with whatever was going on with my phone, like that time is basically entirely empty. I basically, I could see the argument that I wasn't even conscious in a weird way. And that was kind of a scary feeling. That's just time that it's just been rubbed out by,
我都无法说出来。我所做的大部分这种刷手机的行为，以及我至今仍在做的，完全是无意识的。如果我没有关注外部世界（因为我在玩手机），而我显然也没有关注手机上正在发生的事情（像那样的时间基本上完全是空白的）。基本上，可以说我不具备意识，用一种诡异的方式来说。这是一种挺吓人的感觉。那只是一段被抹去的时间，
me just, I guess, going numb from watching reels or doing things on my phone. I really would ask you to ask yourself that same question. Could you do that? Could you tell me the last five videos you've liked on TikTok or the last five things you saw on Instagram that genuinely actually changed your life? Could you give me any kind of recount on the value being provided by your phone or by social media? Yes, there are small things, but I don't think that value outweighs what it would feel like to not be on your phone. I think that we make all these excuses for technology that, no, you know, like I can make online friends and it's made life so much more convenient and it helps me with this and it helps me with that. But let's not kid ourselves. There's so much more value in the real world and being outdoors or being really intensely present with a friend than there is ever going to be from some kind of artificial
因为我只是，我猜，因为看着短视频或在手机上做某些事而变得麻木了。我真的想请你问自己同样的问题。你能做到吗？你能告诉我你在TikTok上点赞的最后五个视频是什么，或者在Instagram上看到的最后五个真正改变了你生活的动态是什么吗？你能说出你的手机或社交媒体所提供的价值的任何明细吗？是的，有一些小的好处，但我不认为这种价值超过了不用手机时的感受。我认为我们为科技找了所有这些借口，不，你知道的，我可以结交网络朋友，这让生活方便得多，它这方面帮了我，那方面帮了我。但我们别自欺欺人了。现实世界、户外活动、或者与朋友进行真正高度专注的陪伴，其价值远远大于我们通过屏幕所获得的任何虚假
connection that we have through a screen. I think the tension that we have with our phones is that they are actually very useful tools and they have, of course, been designed to have all these capabilities and to have convenience in mind. You know, we don't have to carry a map and a notebook and a wallet and a calculator and a flashlight and an address book and a camera around with us. Like, we don't have to carry all of these things and that's pretty marvelous. Definitely is saving our arms and our shoulders from heavy backpacks and heavy tote bags. Like it has been designed to be helpful. It's also been designed to take up as much of our attention as possible,
连接。我认为我们与手机之间的这种拉扯在于，它们确实是非常有用的工具，它们当然被设计成具备所有这些功能，并且把便利性放在首位。你知道，我们不必随身携带地图、笔记本、钱包、计算器、手电筒、地址簿和相机。比如，我们不必随身携带所有这些东西，这真是太了不起了。绝对把我们的手臂和肩膀从沉重的背包和大号手提袋中解放了出来。它的设计初衷就是为了提供帮助。它同时也被设计成尽可能多地占据我们的注意力，
to be an intentional leech. Specifically, the apps we have on them have been created to use the fact that our phones are always close to us and basically an extension of us as a way to really lure us in and to get us to spend more time and in some ways and more money. money on them and more money within these digital spaces. Smartphones and, you know, social media going, go hand in hand. They go hand in hand and they were both really designed around what psychologists call intermittent reinforcement. It omitant reinforcement is the same principles used in gambling. Basically, in gambling, you never know when you're going to get a reward. With your phones,
成为一个刻意的寄生虫。具体来说，我们手机上的应用程序被创造出来，利用了手机总是离我们很近且本质上是我们延伸部分这一事实，以此作为真正诱惑我们、让我们花更多时间和在某种程度上花更多钱的手段。金钱，在这些数字空间里花更多的钱。智能手机和，你知道的，社交媒体，是齐头并进的。它们密不可分，而且两者的设计都是围绕着心理学家所称的间歇性强化。间歇性强化与赌博中使用的原则相同。基本上，在赌博中，你永远不知道什么时候会得到奖励。有了手机，
you never know when you're going to get a ping. You never know when that person's finally going to text you back or you're going to receive a like or a message. So you just keep checking just in case. You just keep scrolling just in case you missed something. And in some ways it becomes quite mindless. What maybe started as a dopamine related and dopamine motivated behavior has now become one that's just like entirely normal and devoid of a lot of feeling. Actually, there have been certain former employees of Google and Facebook and meta. and Yahoo, who have come out and said, this is what we were doing behind the scenes
你永远不知道什么时候会收到提示音。你永远不知道那个人什么时候才会给你回信息，或者你会不会收到一个赞或一条消息。所以你只是不停地查看以防万一。你只是不停地刷屏，以防错过什么。从某种程度上说，这变得非常无意识。曾经可能是由多巴胺相关和多巴胺驱动的行为，现在已经变成了一种完全正常、缺乏很多情感的行为。事实上，谷歌、Facebook、Meta和雅虎的一些前员工曾公开表示，这就是我们在幕后所做的事情
when we were designing these platforms and we were designing these apps. It was called a race for attention. That's literally what it was called because there was this idea, whoever has our attention, has our money, has our ears, has our eyes, can deliver messages, can persuade us,
当我们设计这些平台和这些应用程序时。这被称为争夺注意力的竞赛。这字面意思就是它的名字，因为当时有这样一种想法：谁拥有我们的注意力，就拥有我们的金钱，拥有我们的耳朵，拥有我们的眼睛，就能传递信息，就能说服我们，
can influence us to act one way or another. And that is an incredibly lucrative business model. And so these apps and the people who designed our phones had, you know, literal scientists on their teams being like, how can we make this more alluring, more flashy? What sounds will attract people the most? How can we get people more hooked in? No wonder we can't stop scrolling. You know, our phones were designed to exploit our deepest psychological vulnerabilities, our deepest biological vulnerabilities, you know, the fact that we, crave dopamine, the fact that we crave serotonin and the fact that something like
就能影响我们做出这样或那样的行为。这是一个极其有利可图的商业模式。所以这些应用程序和设计我们手机的人，在他们的团队里有真正的科学家，他们会说：我们怎么能让它更有吸引力、更炫目？什么声音最能吸引人们？我们怎样才能让人类更加欲罢不能？难怪我们停不下来刷手机。你知道，我们的手机就是为了剥削我们最深层的心理脆弱、我们最深层的生物学脆弱而设计的，你知道的，我们渴望多巴胺的事实，我们渴望血清素的事实，以及诸如
Instagram or social media or any number of things can provide us that in like a very nice snack-like bite. I know I'm kind of starting to sound like a bit of a conspiracy theorist here and obviously I don't think that there is some big bad nefarious plot to have us all reliant on technology and unable to devoid enjoyment from anything else. I don't think there's some big plot to slowly control our minds or whatever else people might put out there. But I do think that because we've taken all of these technological advancements for granted, we haven't considered the implications further down the line for our brain, for our neuroplasticity, for how we socialize. Let's examine that for a second because, you know, this technology has only been around for,
Instagram、社交媒体或任何数量的其他事物可以以非常美妙的零食般的一口大小提供给我们。我知道我听起来开始有点像阴谋论者了，而且我显然不认为有什么巨大的、邪恶的阴谋要让我们所有人都依赖技术，无法从其他任何事物中获得乐趣。我不认为有什么阴谋在慢慢控制我们的大脑或人们可能提出的其他什么。但我的确认为，由于我们把所有这些技术进步都视为理所当然，我们没有考虑长远来看对我们的大脑、对我们的神经可塑性、对我们如何社交所带来的影响。让我们花一秒钟来审视这一点，因为，你知道的，这项技术才出现不到
let's say, 20 years. Already we have seen changes to our brains. You've probably seen a few articles here and there exclaiming that our phones are rewiring our minds and then making us less human. The truth is a lot more nuanced than the headline suggests, but yes, there is truth in that statement that smartphones are reshaping the way our brains process information, regulate attention, experience, emotion, think, feel, express empathy, all the things that make us, well, human. One major area of concern that I think is on everyone's minds is obviously attention span. I feel like this has gotten a lot worse for me in the past four years, perhaps since COVID.
比方说20年。我们已经看到大脑发生了变化。你可能在各处看到过一些文章，惊呼手机正在重塑我们的大脑，让我们变得不那么像人了。事实远比头条新闻暗示的要微妙得多，但这种说法确实有其道理，智能手机确实在重塑我们大脑处理信息、调节注意力、体验情感、思考、感受、表达同理心的方式——所有这些让我们成为“人”的特质。我认为每个人心中最关心的一个主要领域显然是注意力持续时间。我觉得过去四年里，这种情况对我来说变得更糟了，也许是从新冠疫情开始的。
Tell me if you feel the same, but I feel like my attention pre-COVID, post-COVID, is so different. And some people will attribute that to smartphone use. So there was a study published in Nature in 2020. that basically found that globally our attention spans have measurably shortened in the last decade. And they link that mainly to rapid fire dopamine-driven-driven feedback loops provided by digital content. You know, apps like TikTok and Instagram are designed to over-stimulate us, and they have trained our brains to kind of expect novelty and expect some new form of entertainment every few seconds.
告诉我你是否有同感，但我觉得我新冠疫情前后的注意力真的太不一样了。有些人会将这归咎于智能手机的使用。《自然》杂志在2020年发表过一项研究，基本上发现全球人类的注意力在过去十年中明显缩短了。他们将其主要归因于数字内容带来的快速、多巴胺驱动的反馈循环。你知道，像抖音和Instagram这样的应用旨在过度刺激我们，它们训练我们的大脑去期待新鲜感，期待每隔几秒钟就能获得某种新的娱乐形式。
And because they've been trained to expect that, it makes sustained long-term focus and attention feel boring and feel almost intolerable. That's why when, you know, you've been in a task for a while, you suddenly will have this weird, almost impulsive urge to scroll. It's like your brain begging for like a treat, begging for like a hit. The problem with that is that many of the tasks were required to do as humans or that we would normally enjoy doing, don't operate on the same dopamine reward scale or the same timeline. Take, for example, working towards a thesis, working towards a big exam and your business idea or long-term project or goal, you're not going to get a hit for a while. The dopamine that comes from successfully completing that big goal or that big task is
正因为它们被训练去期待这一点，使得持续的长期专注和注意力感觉很无聊，甚至几乎无法忍受。这就是为什么当你专注于一项任务一段时间后，你会突然有一种奇怪的、几乎是冲动性的渴望去刷手机。这就像你的大脑在乞求一颗糖果，乞求一次刺激。问题在于，人类被要求去做或我们通常喜欢做的许多任务，并不在同一个多巴胺奖励机制或相同的时间线上运作。以撰写论文、准备大型考试、你的商业想法或长期项目或目标为例，你不会立刻得到刺激。成功完成那个宏大目标或重大任务所带来的多巴胺是
significantly delayed. It's definitely not on a six-second, 12-second, one-minute cycle the way that our phones are operating. There's going to be a lot of repetitive hard work that you will not be rewarded for in the moment. But because we can no longer sustain our attention to focus on those things because we are so used to being rewarded instantly, it can become a lot harder to sustain our focus and our attention on the thing ahead of us and to complete goals. It becomes a lot harder to resist small daily temptations in favor of a more valuable feeling later on. Studies have shown we are becoming worse at delaying gratification. We want the pleasure and we want it now.
明显延迟的。它绝对不像我们使用手机那样，处于6秒、12秒或1分钟的循环中。会有很多重复的艰苦工作，你在当下是得不到回报的。但由于我们无法再维持注意力去专注于那些事情，因为我们太习惯于即时获得奖励，所以很难再将注意力和专注力放在眼前的任务上并完成目标。为了以后更有价值的感觉，去抵制日常的小诱惑变得更加困难。研究表明，我们延迟满足的能力正在变差。我们想要快乐，而且我们现在就要。
That's not good news. We are actually, as a society, less inclined to do hard things. We can't pay attention for as long. And on an emotional level, phones are also interfering with our ability to self-regulate. A study from the University of Texas demonstrated that the mere presence of a smartphone, even if it's off, actually reduces. our available emotional and cognitive capacity. Why? Because part of your attention is always unconsciously monitoring your phone just in case it lights up or it vibrates or someone needs you or
这不是什么好消息。作为一个社会，我们实际上越来越不愿意做困难的事情。我们的注意力无法保持那么久。在情感层面上，手机也在干扰我们的自我调节能力。德克萨斯大学的一项研究表明，仅仅是智能手机的存在（即使它是关机的），实际上也会减少我们可用的情感和认知能力。为什么？因为你的一部分注意力总是在潜意识里监控着你的手机，以防它亮起、震动、有人需要你，或者
it demands your attention. The phone, your phone becomes kind of like a cognitive parasite. It's like quietly siphoning off mental energy even when it's not in use. That's the critical thing, even when it's not in use. This is due to what a psychologist call in the context, the smartphone use, brain drain. We have limited attentional resources. And so if we are constantly exercising our willpower in one way, subconsciously really trying to resist checking our phone,
它需要你的关注。手机，你的手机变得有点像一个认知寄生虫。它就像是在悄悄抽干你的精神能量，即使在不用的时候也是如此。最关键的是，即使在不用的时候。这就是心理学家在智能手机使用的语境下所称的“脑力耗竭”。我们的有限注意力资源是有限的。因此，如果我们不断地以某种方式行使意志力，潜意识里真的很努力地克制自己不去查看手机，
trying really hard to not pay attention to it, we actually are depleting our overall resources in another way. And that's what makes concentrating on another task substantially harder, even if you don't realize it, just the fact that your phone is there and that you want to touch it, even if you're not, is still making what you're doing now more difficult. This effect was strongest in this study amongst the participants who reported being more emotionally dependent on their phones.
非常努力地不去关注它，我们实际上是在以另一种方式耗尽我们的整体资源。这就是为什么集中精力做另一项任务会变得难得多，即使你没有意识到这一点，仅仅因为手机就在那里，而且你想碰它（即使你没有去碰），也会让你现在做的事情变得更加困难。在研究中，这种效应在那些自称对手机情感依赖更强的参与者身上最为强烈。
So people who said they used their phone to deal with difficult feelings. They resorted to drowning out uncomfortable thoughts using social media, using these proxy forms of social connection. There was one question that was like, I can't remember what it said, but it was basically like, can you imagine, can you imagine dealing with this situation and it was like someone breaking up with you
所以那些说自己用手机来应对困难情绪的人。他们诉诸于用社交媒体、用这些替代形式的社交连接来淹没不舒服的想法。有一个问题大概是，我不记得具体怎么说的了，但基本上就像是：你能想象，你能想象在没有手机的情况下应对这种情况吗？比如有人跟你分手，
without having your phones, you think it would make it worse? And almost everyone was like, oh yeah. There were all these questions that basically showed that our phones are like a little security blanket, like we're children. And when we're sad or when we're lonely or when we're tired,
你觉得这会让情况变得更糟吗？几乎所有人都说，哦，是的。所有这些问题基本上都表明，我们的手机就像是一条小毛毯，就像我们还是孩子。当我们难过、孤独或疲倦时，
we go to them for nourishment in a weird way. Let's also talk about social connection for a second here because I think it's probably one of the most important parts of this conversation. Everyone, everyone wants to talk about it. Do our phones make friendship and dating harder or do they make it easier? I feel like everyone's split down the middle. Half the people say, no, you know, I'm more connected than ever. The other half say, yeah, you might be more connected, but is that real connection. For me, I personally think that our phones are again a tool. But when they become the only tool through which we can connect with others, they're not useful anymore. Like they've served their purpose almost too much to the form of
我们就会以一种奇怪的方式向它们寻求滋养。这里我们顺便聊聊社交连接，因为我认为这可能是这场对话中最最重要的部分之一。每个人，每个人都想谈论这个。我们的手机是让友谊和约会变得更难了，还是变得更容易了？我觉得大家的意见分成两半。一半的人说，不，你知道的，我比以往任何时候都联系得更紧密了。另一半人则说，是的，你可能联系得更紧密了，但那真的是真正的连接吗？对我来说，我个人认为手机依然只是一个工具。但当它们成为我们与他人连接的唯一工具时，它们就不再有用了。就像它们的用途发挥得太过了，
reliance. I saw this tweet the other day that I think captures the price we've paid for this convenience and this ease beautifully. This person said, our phones and social media, they don't work because humans are inherently social. They work because they figured out how to replace real connection with the artificial sensation that we are connecting. Artificial because it doesn't require either person to be truly present or invested in the other person. You can maintain a friendship through a series of happy birthday messages through sending reels back and forth. Your dating life can become looking at thousands of faces over and over again rather than walking into a bar and feeling the spark in real life. And so no, it's not the same, but in some
甚至达到了依赖的程度。我前几天看到这条推文，我认为它完美地抓住了我们为这种便利和轻松所付出的代价。这个人说，我们的手机和社交媒体，它们不起作用并不是因为人类生来就是社交动物，而是因为它们摸索出了如何用“我们正在连接”这种人工感觉来取代真实的连接。之所以说是人工的，是因为它不需要任何一方真正出席或投入到对方身上。你可以通过一系列生日祝福信息、互相转发短视频来维持一段友谊。你的约会生活可能会变成一遍又一遍地看成千上万张脸，而不是走进酒吧去感受现实生活中的火花。所以，不，这不一样，但在某种
more way we've been made to feel like it is. Psychologists have actually given that experience a name. The experience of, I guess, having these like bite-sized small moments of connection in like a digital space that aren't real but kind of sustain us until we can meet up in person. They call them social snacks or they call this process social snacking, these brief digital interactions that mimic the nutrients of real connection are important and they do sustain us over time like a snacks, snacks between a meal, but they are not a meal. They don't fill us. And over time, as these micro interactions become the default, they actually begin to substitute the
更深的方式上，我们被塑造成了觉得它是一样的。心理学家实际上给这种体验起了一个名字。我猜，这种在数字空间中拥有微小、一口大小的连接时刻的体验，它们不是真实的，但某种程度上维持了我们，直到我们可以面基。他们称之为“社交零食”或将这个过程称为“社交吃零食”（social snacking），这些简短的数字互动模仿了真实连接的养分，它们很重要，并且随着时间的推移确实能维持我们，就像正餐之间的零食一样，但它们不是正餐。它们不能填饱我们的肚子。随着时间的推移，当这些微互动成为默认设置时，它们实际上开始替代了
real thing. You know, a phone call no longer needs to take place if you feel like, you know, you're kind of full on just texting them throughout the day. Laughing with someone until you cry doesn't happen as much. Really like sitting down, being present with your friends for a weekend and not pulling up your phone to show them something or not, you know, being like, oh, what were you talking about? Because you've been distracted by a notification. It just doesn't, like, that's all that happens these days. Like there is no just sitting down and being like, I'm here, you're here. Let's be completely present. and no, there isn't something more interesting that I want to be doing. When connection just becomes, like, I guess, an exchange of content,
真实的事物。你知道，如果你觉得一整天都在和对方发信息已经让你感到饱足了，那么电话沟通就不再需要发生了。和某人笑到流泪的情况不再那么常见了。真正地坐下来，和你的朋友共度一个周末，不掏出手机给他们看什么，或者不表现得像……哦，你在聊什么？因为你被通知打扰了。事情根本就不是这样的，现在发生的只有这些。就像根本没有所谓的“坐下来，我在这里，你在这里，让我们完全专注”，
we do lose the intimacy that comes from actually knowing and being known by another person. And then sometimes you can't get to the point where because you've been snacking all day, like social snacking, I guess, you're so tired by that that you can't even do the real thing. Like, all of this technology is meant to be helping us and making the real thing more convenient. it but then when you're so exhausted by all the stuff that happens in between, you don't make it happen. Hopefully this is making sense, but what I've been finding is that I can't even be bothered to reply to texts or to reply to reels or to messages anymore because it's just so overwhelming. There's just so much. And as soon as I open my phone, it's like, oh my God, there's like 50 people
而且没有其他我想做的更有趣的事。当连接仅仅变成了一种内容交换，
or whatever, like I need to reply to. Or it's just, this actually feels like more effort for less outcome and so unless someone's like messaging me to make plans like I'm not particularly engaged but I also realize that so much of how other people interact with each other takes place in those in between moments so that's the dilemma like you both want to participate and you want to be around for those moments you also are kind of exhausted by this process and you understand how over reliant you are on it so you do want to take a step back like it's kind of exhausting really. Hopefully that dilemma makes sense. The more I think about it, you know, the more, it does kind of sound like a toxic relationship, right? Like me and my phone are in a toxic
我们确实失去了真正了解一个人并被另一个人了解所带来的亲密感。然后有时你甚至无法达到那种状态，因为你一整天都在吃零食，就像社交吃零食一样，你对此感到太累了，以至于你甚至无法进行真实的事情。所有这些科技本意是帮助我们，让真实的事情更方便，但当你被介于中间的所有事情弄得精疲力竭时，你根本无法让它发生。希望这说得通，但我发现的是，我甚至懒得去回复短信、短视频或消息了，因为这实在太让人应接不暇了。事情太多了。一打开手机，就会觉得，天哪，有大约50个人
relationship. We need to break up. It's like when you get to that point with someone when, like, you can't be with them anymore, but you also don't know life without them. So you're just kind of like hoping it will get better or like working up the courage to do it. That's literally what this feels like. It's kind of funny, honestly, like talking about these inanimate objects. like it's a bad boyfriend, but it kind of is. It's this boyfriend that like actually keeps telling you that like you can't live without them, but you probably couldn't. So with that in mind, let's take a step back. Let's take a step away. Have a short break. Go have some water. Go have a tea. And let's come back and talk about solutions as well as some more stories of people who have gone completely technology
之类的人需要我回复。或者只是，这实际上感觉是以更少的收获付出更多的努力，所以除非有人发消息给我安排计划，否则我并不是特别投入。但我也意识到，其他人之间的大多数互动都发生在那些夹缝中的时刻，这就是两难境地：你既想参与，想出现在那些时刻，又被这个过程搞得筋疲力竭，并且明白自己对它的依赖有多深，所以你的确想退一步。这真的很累人。希望这种两难境地讲得通。我越想它，就越觉得它听起来像是一段有毒的关系，对吧？就像我和我的手机处于一段有毒的
free, whether they regret it, what they've learned, whether they would recommend it as well. All of that and more after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience
关系中。我们需要分手。这就像你和某人发展到那种地步，你再也不能和他们在一起了，但你又不知道没有他们的生活该怎么过。所以你只能寄希望于情况会变好，或者鼓起勇气去这样做。这简直就是这种感觉。老实说，这挺搞笑的，谈论这些无生命的物体就像谈论一个糟糕的男朋友，但它确实有点像。这个男朋友不断告诉你，你没有它们就活不下去，而你可能确实离不开。因此，考虑到这一点，让我们退后一步。让我们抽身离开。休息一会儿。去喝点水，去喝杯茶。然后回来讨论解决方案，以及一些彻底摆脱科技的人的故事，
in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the well. this industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress.
看看他们是否后悔，学到了什么，是否会推荐这样做。在这段短暂的休息之后，将为您呈现所有这些以及更多精彩内容。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧、健身以及在这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康与健身专家等展开对话，超越主导健康行业的那些不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾认为种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。
I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of Congress. crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack.
经历一些磨难，你会作为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。即Heart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方上的T-W-O-Percent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上双击（拍打）小金（Little Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。
So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your
我是萨姆·杰特（Sam Jett）。我是亚历克斯·英国（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过那段日期的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，他滔滔不绝地谈论了80年代的霹雳瘾（crack）。需要明确的是，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为国会。霹雳瘾。我随时准备聊聊84年的霹雳瘾，但只是想让大家知道。我的意思是，马克，在这一点上，这是我们讨论霹雳瘾的第二集了。
Podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field
所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿线。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你把话说完。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在iHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《回顾过去》。
and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it.
欢迎来到我的新播客《硬着头皮学》（Learn the Hard Way），我是您的主持人、您最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了我在心理健康领域超过十年的经验，
And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太深陷于追逐之中，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西，却还在继续追逐。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
而且我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是的。
In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正地做一个好人。加入我，卡尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《硬着头皮学》中，就治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeart Radio应用。搜索《硬着头皮学》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Echard）发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的风口浪尖。随后的家事法庭听证会暴露出她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这开启了一场历时多年的法庭之战以证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士：格雷格·莱斯皮安（Greg Alespian）和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《爱情陷阱》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until Justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. So I've been really fascinated, particularly by stories of people who have stepped away from social media and their phones entirely. And what happened to them afterwards?
女士们先生们，美利科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因涉嫌欺诈被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这件事还远远没有结束。请在Iheart电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。所以，我一直非常着迷，特别是那些完全远离社交媒体和手机的人的故事。以及他们之后发生了什么？
I feel like it's like, I'm watching from afar, seeing their experience. They're my guinea pigs. and you're probably going to hate what I have to say next. All of them love it. Literally every single person who has a story about quitting their phone, all of them are like, I'm happier, I'm lighter, I'm more productive, I smell the flowers, animals come up to me, food tastes better, like all of them have a story like that.
我觉得这就好像我在远处观看，看着他们的经历。他们是我的小白鼠。你可能接下来会讨厌我要说的话。他们所有人都爱死这种状态了。真的，每一个讲述戒掉手机故事的人，他们都说：我更快乐了，我更轻松了，我更有效率了，我闻到了花香，动物会向我走来，食物尝起来更美味了，所有人都有类似的故事。
One woman who quit her smartphone for a year and wrote this big article about it even said that that year felt like the longest year she'd ever lived. because she basically gained more time or a greater perception of time, which, like, that feels pretty profound. I think a lot of us could do with more time in our day and a sense of more time in our lives, more time to do things, experience things. She's saying that gave that to her. An even more, like, kind of shocking example or story of this was a town in France that has
有一个女人戒掉智能手机一年，并为此写了一篇长文，她甚至说，那一年感觉就像她经历过的最漫长的一年。因为她基本上获得了更多的时间，或者说对时间有了更深刻的感知，这感觉相当深远。我想我们很多人都希望一天中有更多的时间，在生活中感受到更多的时间，有更多的时间去做事情、去体验。她说，这一切都是它带给她的。一个更令人震惊的例子或故事是法国的一个小镇，
gone completely phone-free. This town is like 50 kilometers away from Paris. There's 2,000 people. It's called Sain Point, S-Port, I think. S-E-I-N-E-P-O-T, S-P-O-T-Port. Very interesting. Basically, like, back in 2024, they voted on this and their mayor was like, do we want to go phone free?
那里已经完全不使用手机了。这个镇距离巴黎大约50公里。有2000人口。它叫塞纳波（Sain Point），或者S-Port，我想是这样的。S-E-I-N-E-P-O-T，S-P-O-T-Port。非常有趣。基本上，早在2024年，他们就此进行了投票，他们的镇长问：我们想摆脱手机吗？
54% of them said yes. And so mobile phones are banned in public places. like you walk down the street apparently and like you just don't see phones it's like you're from a completely different time and i don't know how they enforce that like whether it's a fine or whatnot but people apparently really really love it i'm sure some hate it but from the article that interviewed the mayor he was like people really enjoy this idea of just being present with their neighbors and they're watchful and they're really enjoying their community rather than just feeling sucked into this device that gives the impression of community you know when you
54%的人投了赞成票。因此，公共场所禁止使用手机。比如你走在街上，显然你看不到手机，就像你来自一个完全不同的时代一样。我不知道他们是怎么执行这一规定的，是罚款还是其他什么，但人们显然非常非常喜欢它。我确信有些人讨厌它，但从采访镇长的文章来看，他说人们真的很喜欢这种与邻居共处、保持警觉的想法，他们真的很享受自己的社区，而不是觉得自己被吸入了这样一个设备中——它给你一种社区的错觉，你知道，当你
read blog posts and stories of people who have quit their phones, it is, it feels like people talking about being converted to a new religion. And yes, of course, a lot of these cases are anecdotal and they're based on someone's personal experiences, but the science does back up some of their personal findings, that their perspective, their worldview, their brains feel like they've been changed. The biggest claim that's come out of the scientific community, community recently is that just being without your phone for 72 hours or partaking in a three-day reset creates changes in your brain activity that researchers can physically observe and see. So this particular study, which I feel like has been talked about everywhere recently,
阅读那些戒掉手机的人的博客文章和故事时，你会觉得这就像人们在谈论皈依一种新宗教。是的，当然，其中许多案例都是轶事，基于个人的亲身经历，但科学确实支持了他们的一些个人发现：他们的观点、世界观、大脑感觉都发生了改变。科学界最近得出的最大结论是，仅仅离开手机72小时，或者参与为期三天的重置，就会在研究人员可以肉眼观察到的层面上改变你的大脑活动。所以这个特别的研究，我觉得最近到处都在讨论，
it was published just earlier this year in March 2025 by the University of Cologne and Heidelberg University in Germany. And they took a number of people between the age of 18 and 30, and they basically said, you are not allowed to use your phone for three days. Unless you are literally an emergency, do not use your phone for three days. And during this three-day period, the researchers conducted psychological tests, and they used brain scans using fMRI to kind of just examine what they were seeing and what the effects were of restricting phone usage. The brain scans were kind of shocking.
它是在今年早些时候的2025年3月由德国科隆大学和海德堡大学发表的。他们找了一些18到30岁之间的人，基本上对他们说：你们三天内不允许使用手机。除非你真的遇到了紧急情况，否则三天内不要使用手机。在这三天里，研究人员进行了心理测试，并使用fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）进行脑部扫描，以检查他们所看到的情况以及限制使用手机的效果。脑部扫描结果相当惊人。
They showed the brains of basically. basically people in withdrawal. Very similar to how the brain of someone withdrawing from drugs or alcohol would look. There were these huge shifts in the reward and craving regions of the brain. And whilst they weren't entirely clear on why this was, they basically suggested that because not using your phone is a kind of withdrawal from a dopamine source, your brain is very quickly trying to rewire how it can seek out stimulation and pleasure. elsewhere when it's been overly reliant on one source for a long time. This is just one finding among so many studies.
它们显示的大脑状态基本上是戒断状态。非常类似于戒毒或戒酒者的大脑外观。大脑的奖控制和渴求区域发生了巨大的变化。虽然他们并不完全清楚原因何在，但他们基本上认为，由于不使用手机是对多巴胺来源的一种戒断，当大脑长期过度依赖单一来源时，它会非常迅速地试图重新布线，寻找其他途径来寻求刺激和快乐。这只是众多研究中的一个发现。
And a lot of these studies, I think, have cropped up largely in response to this new anti-technology revolution. And whether not using your phone does make a difference because you kind of have these natural groups that you can test against. Like you have a natural control group. You have a natural experimental group because a lot of people have resorted to not using their phones, whereas there's another large majority who use their phones excessively. Another one of these studies was done in 2022. It focused more on mood. And this time they asked
而且我认为，很多这类研究的出现，很大程度上是为了回应这场反技术的革命。不使用手机是否会产生影响，因为你有可以进行测试的天然群体。就像你拥有一个天然的对照组。你拥有一个天然的实验组，因为许多人已经诉诸于不使用手机，而另一个绝大多数人则过度使用手机。另一项此类研究于2022年完成。它更多地关注情绪。这一次，他们要求
people to go without their smartphones for a week. Almost all participants reported significantly lower levels of anxiety, specifically social anxiety, and much higher levels of life satisfaction. For example, a lot of them said their days had more good moments than bad when they weren't using their phone. They said they found themselves smiling more. They said they found themselves more emotional and more in touch with their emotions and that they had better social interactions. Without this constant influx of notifications and stimuli, you know, I think what's really happening is that the brain is allowed to return to its natural rhythm, one that, yes, does include boredom and it will include scary thoughts sometimes, but also creative thoughts and deep
人们连续一周不使用智能手机。几乎所有参与者都报告说，焦虑水平（特别是社交焦虑）明显降低，生活满意度大大提高。例如，许多人表示，在不使用手机的日子里，美好的时刻比糟糕的时刻要多。他们说发现自己笑得更多了。他们说自己变得更有情绪，更能体会自己的情感，并且拥有更好的社交互动。没有源源不断的通知和刺激，你知道，我认为真正发生的事情是，大脑得以回归其自然的节奏，这个节奏确实包含无聊，有时也会包含恐惧的想法，但同时也包含创造性的想法和深度
focus and when any of these things come up, they're not immediately stifled by the insertion of a screen. They are allowed to flow naturally and when people get into the rhythm of that flow, they feel more human. Also, to be expected, sleep improved. We know that blue light exposure from our phones is really bad for our circadian rhythm, but I think the most profound thing from this study wasn't that they were happier. It's that actually not having a phone didn't decimate their friendships. And obviously it was only for a week, but there are so many other examples of people who, you know, are in their 20s or in their 30s who have given up their phone thinking that it was going to mean a lot of phombo, thinking that it was going to make them
专注。当这些情况出现时，它们不会立即被屏幕的介入所扼杀。它们得以自然流淌，当人们进入这种流淌的节奏时，他们会觉得自己更像一个人了。同样在意料之中，睡眠得到了改善。我们知道手机产生的蓝光照射对我们的生物钟非常不好，但我认为这项研究最深刻的地方不在于他们更快乐了。实际上，没有手机并没有摧毁他们的友谊。很明显这只持续了一周，但还有那么多20多岁或30多岁的人放弃了手机，以为这意味着会错过很多东西（FOMO），以为这会让他们
more disconnected, that it was going to be harder for them to see their friends. And it turns out that it's the complete opposite. People report that it actually gave them a clear review of which friends would make an effort, also because they removed that social snacking in between. They saw their friends more often. They made more plans and they had more fun during those plans. More fun than a lot of them could remember having for a long time. You know, these moments were richer, they were more fulfilling, they were more enjoyable. And so I think that's something that a lot of people like me, in their 20s want to hear is that going without your phone or social media isn't going to destroy your life.
更加疏离，以为见朋友会变得更难。事实证明，情况完全相反。人们报告说，这实际上让他们看清了哪些朋友愿意付出努力，而且因为他们消除了中间的社交“零食”。他们更常见到朋友了。他们做了更多的计划，并且在这些计划中获得了更多的乐趣。比他们记忆中很长时间以来感受到的乐趣还要多。你知道，这些时刻更丰富、更充实、更令人愉快。所以我想这是很多像我这样20多岁的人想听到的：不使用手机或社交媒体并不会毁了你的生活。
We've been made to feel so reliant on this thing so that we can't stop. Here are these brave people who have said, actually, like, on the other side, it's never as bad as you think it is. In fact, it may actually be better, is what I'm hearing. So for those of you playing at home, I think the evidence is kind of stacked against me when it comes to whether I should break up with my phone. phone or not. Like if I was doing a pro-cons list for this relationship, the cons of keeping my phone definitely outweigh the pros. Let's think about the evidence for a second. More productive.
我们被灌输得觉得自己对这个东西极度依赖，以至于无法停下来。这里有这些勇敢的人，他们说，其实在另一边，情况从来没有你想象的那么糟。事实上，我听到的是，情况可能实际上更好。所以对于那些在家听节目的人来说，当权衡我是不是该和手机“分手”时，证据似乎对我很不利。如果我为这段关系列一个优缺点清单，保留手机的缺点绝对超过了优点。让我们想一想这些证据。更高效的生产力。
Better sleep. Better friendships. More neural pathways. Evidence against it. Less convenience. Maybe less connection to my job for me personally because I work for myself. But, you know, would that necessarily be a bad thing? I think a lot of my family and friends my boyfriend would definitely say like no maybe not being connected to your job 24-7 would be a good thing they're probably right so obviously i've been thinking about this before i sat down to recall this and i've been thinking about what a breakup with my phone would look like and i do think it would have to be rather gradual rather than like a full-blown rip the band-aid off i know i was talking at the start about having this real big impulse to just say goodbye and never come back but i think it's going to be
更好的睡眠。更好的友谊。更多的神经通路。反对的证据。不太方便。对我个人来说，可能与我的工作联系较少，因为我是自由职业者。但是，你知道，这一定会是件坏事吗？我想我的很多家人、朋友、我的男朋友肯定会说：不，不和工作24/7保持连线可能会是一件好事。他们可能是对的。所以很明显，在我坐下来录音之前我一直在思考这个问题，我也一直在思考与手机分手的过程会是什么样子，我确实认为这必须是一个渐进的过程，而不是那种彻底一刀切的做法。我知道我一开始还在谈论这种强烈的冲动，想直接说再见，再也不回头，但我认为这会是一个
a slower thing. This is what I'm committing to. And I'm just going to say what my plan is, if you want to follow along at home and try these, you're more than welcome. I can't say I'm going to be entirely successful, but I want to see if I can do this for a month. We're going to start with the things I'm already doing and then we're going to move on from there, the things that I want to do to see if I could go kind of phone free in for how long. The first thing I'm already doing, and if you listen to the podcast, you'll know I've been doing this for a while. I charge my phone outside of my bedroom and I have like an old school alarm clock. It's literally like a silver alarm clock that goes like, d-da-d-d-ding, and then you like hit it over the head. It's like
更慢的过程。这就是我所承诺的。如果你们想在家里跟着尝试，我非常欢迎。我不能保证自己会完全成功，但我想看看我是否能坚持一个月。我们将从我已经在做的事情开始，然后从那里继续前进，看看我想做的事情，看看我能否做到不带手机，以及坚持多久。第一件我已经在大做特做的事，如果你听过这个播客，你就会知道我已经这样做一段时间了。我把手机放在卧室外面充电，我有一个老式的闹钟。它字面意义上就像一个银色的闹钟，会发出“叮——”的声音，然后你得一巴掌拍在它头上。就像
if you've seen Ferris Bueller's day off, which I'm sure most of you have. Like it's literally stereotypical like 1990s silver alarm clock. And it's been great because firstly it makes me get out of bed a lot quicker. Maybe because I do want to check my phone. But also because I'm like, oh, if I don't get up with this one, like, there's not going to be seven more alarms that are going to go off. And so that's been really, really useful. And I will say, like, I don't immediately go to my phone. I do get up and do other things. So it's not the first thing I say and the last thing I say morning and night. Secondly, I've been, like, slowly transitioning to only having social media on my work iPad. I feel very lucky that I have the additional technology and additional means to be able to do this.
如果你看过电影《春天不是读书天》（Ferris Bueller's Day Off），我确信你们大多数人都看过。它字面意义上就是那种刻板印象里的1990年代银色闹钟。这太棒了，首先它让我更快地起床。也许是因为我确实想检查手机。但也因为我想：哦，如果我不随着这个闹钟起床，就不会有另外七个闹钟陆续响起了。所以这真的非常非常有用。而且我要说的是，我不会立刻去看手机。我会起床做别的事。所以它不是我早晨醒来和晚上睡觉时接触的第一个和最后一个东西。其次，我一直在慢慢过渡，只在我的工作iPad上保留社交媒体。我觉得自己很幸运，有额外的技术和手段能够做到这一点。
but I just social media, like it's just too freaking available. People are too available. We shouldn't be able to look at everyone's lives all the time and think that that's normal and think that seeing a million little tiny videos every single day is what our brain chemistry was made to respond to. So having it on my iPad definitely gives me like a cognitive distance and it gives me like a barrier or like a friction barrier. Like it's not easy.
但我只是觉得社交媒体太他妈容易接触到了。人们太容易联系到了。我们本不应该随时随地看着每个人的生活，还认为那是正常的，还认为每天看一百万个小视频是我们的大脑化学机制天生就要应对的。所以把它放在我的iPad上肯定给了我一种认知距离，它给了我一个屏障，或者说摩擦屏障。它并不容易。
it's not immediate. Like I do actually have to go and turn it on and charge it and find it to be able to use it. And it's kind of bulky and it's kind of hard. So having that barrier, fantastic. Thirdly, when I have my phone and if you're my friend, you know this, I constantly have to not disturb on. Constantly, it's probably very frustrating. But it's so that I can check it when I want to rather than when it wants me to pay attention. Like I feel like it's switching the script on who has power in this.
它不是即时的。我确实必须去把它打开、充电、找到它才能使用。而且它有点笨重，有点困难。所以有这样一个屏障，简直太棒了。第三，当我有手机时，如果你是我的朋友，你就会知道这一点，我总是开着“请勿打扰”模式。一直都开着，这可能非常令人沮丧。但这是为了让我可以在我想看的时候检查它，而不是当它希望我注意它的时候。我觉得这转换了这段关系中谁拥有主导权的剧本，
this relationship, me on my phone. Like, do not disturb, kind of doesn't give it a voice. So I can just, um, only check it when I want to check it. I found that very, very helpful. Fourth thing I've been doing, I cannot use two devices at the same time. Can't watch TV and be on my phone. And the way that I've been trying to not do that is obviously just pay more attention. Like when I'm doing one thing, I'm doing one thing. But also I've been kind of slowly accumulating other activities to do whilst I'm watching TV at night, whilst I'm kind of sitting at the couch and it's just like background noise. Sudoko, um, that stuff, like, it is so much fun doing Sudoku. I've become a little bit obsessed with it. Like, I can't leave the house unless I've
是我还是手机。就像，“请勿打扰”模式让它没有了声音。所以我可以……嗯，只在我想要检查的时候检查它。我发现这非常非常有用。第四件我一直在做的事，我不能同时使用两台设备。不能一边看电视一边玩手机。我一直在尝试不这样做的方法显然就是更加专注。比如当我做一件事时，我就只做一件事。但我也在慢慢积累其他活动，以便在晚上看电视时、坐在沙发上把它当背景噪声时做。数独（Sudoko），嗯，那种东西，玩数独太有趣了。我变得有点痴迷了。比如，如果我没有
done, like, a couple. I've got one of those, like, big books from the news agency and I've done half of it. Now, whenever I catch flats, I always found, like, the Sudoku and, like, the back of the magazine. It's so engaging. I feel like I'm also doing a lot for my long-term brain health in terms of protecting against dementia. Like I'm doing these little brain exercises every single day. And you can just kind of sit there and like mindlessly do it and still be kind of focusing. I also, someone got me a Lego set the other day. So much fun. Like Lego is, it's literally a billion industry. So I'm not surprising anyone when I say that I'm enjoying it. I'm sure a lot of people enjoy it. But it feels amazing. It feels so great doing something with your hands whilst you know,
做完几道题，我就无法离开家。我从报刊亭买了一本那种厚厚的书，现在已经做了一半了。现在，每当我坐飞机，我总会在杂志后面找到数独。它太吸引人了。我觉得我也在为长期的脑健康做很多事情，比如预防痴呆症。就像我每天都在做这些微小的大脑练习。你可以就坐在那里，无意识地做着它，同时还能集中注意力。另外，前几天有人送了我一套乐高积木。太有趣了。乐高是一个价值数十亿美元的产业，所以我说我喜欢它并没有让任何人感到惊讶。我确信很多人都喜欢它。但这种感觉棒极了。一边用双手做着事情，一边你知道，
you're watching your TV show, especially if you're someone who struggles to just concentrate on one thing at once. A friend of mine is also teaching me how to knit, my beautiful friend, Gia. She made me this gorgeous scarf and I was like, I feel like I need to learn how to make something because how often, how many of us know how to like truly make something these days. Like, you know, maybe some of us know how to like make cookies or like if you really tried you could make like a box out of wood but we're really losing like these skills that we used to perfect long ago and so getting back to that and like having someone who is really good at something be able to teach me it's also like a fun social thing I actually saw someone the other day talk about how in their journey to kind of
看着你的电视节目，感觉太美妙了，特别是如果你是一个很难一次只专心做一件事的人。我的一个朋友也在教我如何织毛衣，我美丽的朋友吉娅（Gia）。她给我织了这条华丽的围巾，我当时就想，我觉得我需要学习如何制作一些东西，因为现在我们当中有多少人还知道如何真正地制作一件东西呢？你看，也许我们中的有些人知道如何做曲奇，或者如果你真的努力了，你可以用木头做一个盒子，但我们真的在失去那些我们过去完美掌握的技能。所以回归这一点，并且有一个在这方面真的很擅长的人来教我，这也变成了一件有趣社交的事情。我前几天实际上看到有人在谈论，在他们戒掉手机的旅程中，
stop using their phone as much they had a boarder menu they found that their major trigger for using their phone even when they didn't want to was just that they had run out of things to do and like their brain was just obviously pleasure hunting and like stimulation hunting. So she has this big list of things to do when she's bored, including chores, including things that she would never normally have on her to do list that are things she kind of wants to do. Like that is something that I think I need to implement more. Obviously, I've done it a little bit.
他们有一个无聊菜单（boredom menu）。他们发现，即使在他们不想用手机时，使用手机的主要诱因也只是因为他们无事可做了，而且大脑显然在寻找快乐和刺激。所以她有一张很大的清单，列出了无聊时可以做的事情，包括家务，包括那些她平时永远不会列入待办事项、但又是她有点想做的事情。这正是我想投入更多去实践的。很显然，我已经做了一点。
I can see how that would be very effective. This is also something I'm working towards, which is using grey scale. on my phone. I don't do this all the time. I actually find it to be, well, I think the point is, is that it's meant to make the appeal of the phone less alluring by putting everything in black, white,
我能看出这会非常有效。这也是我正在努力的一点，那就是在手机上使用灰度模式。我并不是一直都这样做。我其实发现它……嗯，我想重点是，它本意是通过将所有东西变成黑白灰色，来削弱手机的诱惑力，
and grey, but I find it sometimes going to give me a headache. But the technique, like, is definitely effective. By removing colour, I definitely have noticed that there's, like, less accidental sensory overload. So that is something that is definitely a quick. I think a quick replacement, quick fix that gets to like the root of the problem. Also, I have ordered a flip phone and I'm going to keep you updated on how it goes, but it's pink.
但我发现它有时会让我头疼。不过这种技术确实很有效。通过去除颜色，我确实注意到较少发生意外的感官过载。所以这绝对是一个小技巧。我认为这是一个快速的替代方案，能触及问题根源的快速修复方法。另外，我订购了一部翻盖手机，我会随时向大家更新它的使用情况，它是粉红色的。
It was like $100 from Officeworks. And I'm excited for it to arrive. Like, I think it's going to be a fun little accessory. And what I really want to do is just begin by taking it to the park when I walk my dog and like just giving that number to my boyfriend and to to my close friends and to, like, my parents. And then taking it, like, to run errands. And then taking it for, like, day trips or, like, into work so that I'm not entirely disconnected, but there is, like, not this, not the brain drain of the iPhone being next
在Officeworks花了一百块钱左右。我很期待它送达。我觉得它会是一个有趣的小配件。我真正想做的是，先带着它去公园遛狗，把这个号码只告诉我的男朋友、好朋友和父母。然后带着它去跑腿办事。然后带着它去进行一日游，或者带去上班，这样我就不会完全与世隔绝，但又不会有iPhone就在我身边、让我随时想要滚动屏幕、滑动和做各种事情的那种脑力消耗，仅仅因为它就在那儿。特别是当我通勤时，或者当我处于
to me that I constantly feel inclined to, like, scroll and swipe and do things on, just because it's there. Especially, like, when I'm commuting or when I'm just, like, in. moments of stillness. I really want to try and not just feel like the first thing I can do to entertain myself is to pick up this device that requires absolutely no active energy from me. One thing I will say about the flip phone though, and if you have a flip phone, tell me how you are going with this is that I kind of want a camera on me.
静止的时刻时。我真的很想努力不让娱乐自己的第一反应就是拿起这个完全不需要我付出任何主动精力的设备。不过关于翻盖手机有一点我要说，如果你有一部翻盖手机，告诉我你是怎么应对的——那就是我还是希望身上能有个相机。
I feel like that's going to be the biggest issue especially with like restaurants all having QR codes these days. I think that's going to be, I guess you. You could always order at the counter, but also just, you know, if my dog does something cute, or if I see something cool, I do think I'll miss that. But I think we cross the bridge, that bridge, when we come to it. I also don't want to replace one technology with like a thousand more pieces of technology. I don't think that's realistic.
我觉得这将是最大的问题，特别是现在所有餐厅都有二维码。我想这会是……我想你总是可以在柜台点餐，但也你知道，如果我的狗做了一个可爱的动作，或者我看到了很酷的东西，我确实会错过这一点。但我想车到山前必有路。我也不想用一种技术去取代成千上万种更多的技术。我不认为这很现实。
You know, I feel like I've spoken about getting the iPad and there's one piece of technology and then getting the flip phone. That's two pieces of technology and then getting the camera. It's like, that's three. and it's like, I kind of see why they made these, obviously. But finally, I think with that, I do kind of want to work up to doing phone-free weekends. No phone. One of my friends, Meg, like recently went away with her boyfriend and she left her phone in Sydney
你知道，我觉得我一直在谈论买iPad，这是一种技术；然后买翻盖手机，那是两种技术；然后又买相机，这就变成三种了。我就觉得，我有点明白他们为什么会设计这些东西了，很显然。但最后，我想顺便说一句，我确实想逐步做到周末不带手机。没有手机。我的一个朋友梅格（Meg）最近和她男友去度假，她把手机留在了悉尼，
and she was telling me how, like, the first hour she was, like, kind of panicking. And then she was like, oh, doesn't really matter. So no phone for a weekend and then maybe no phone for a week on holiday, that's something I want to work up to. I'm going to report back. Please hold me accountable. If someone can like DM me, if you're listening to this in like three months, can you DM me and say, hey, did you end up doing that?
她告诉我，第一个小时她有点惊慌失措。然后她就想，哦，其实也没什么大不了的。所以一个周末没有手机，然后可能在假期里一周没有手机，这是我想努力做到的。我会回来汇报的。请监督我。如果有人能私信我，如果你在大概三个月后听到这个，你能私信我问：“嘿，你最后真的那样做了吗？”
So that I feel some sense of like external responsibility. Mainly, I think just being aware of how much time my phone has drained out of my life has been important in itself. I have a lot of excuses. Some of them may even be valid. but the only person I'm making those excuses to is me and I'm also the one who's suffering the consequences. And so I think a big part of this is just having a frank chat with myself and being like, does your phone usage and does your technology usage actually align with how you see yourself
这样我就会感受到某种外部责任感。最主要的是，仅仅意识到手机耗费了我生活中多少时间，这一点本身就很重要。我有很多借口。其中有些甚至可能是合理的。但我向之辩解的唯一对象只有我自己，而承受后果的也是我。所以我想这很大一部分在于与自己进行一次坦诚的对话，然后问：你的手机使用习惯和技术使用习惯，真的符合你对自己的看法吗？
and actually align with how you see your life? Because the answer is no, I don't see myself as someone who wants to waste time and I don't see myself as doing things that are completely at times you're and I have a lot of things I want to achieve and I have a lot of projects that I'm working on. And I am feeling very time poor at the same time. It's like, well, I can't be sitting here saying that I'm time poor if I have time to scroll for six to seven hours a day. Like two things cannot be true. So I want to just reclaim my attention for myself and I want to reclaim my time for myself and just sit and be present with what I'm doing. And I think this will be a good challenge for that.
真的符合你对生活的愿景吗？因为答案是否定的，我不认为自己是一个想浪费时间的人，我也不认为自己做的事情在某些时候是……而且我有很多想要实现的目标，我有很多正在进行的项目。与此同时，我又觉得时间非常匮乏。这就好比，如果我有时间每天刷手机六到七个小时，我就不能坐在这里说自己时间匮乏。这两件事不可能同时成立。所以我只想为自己夺回注意力，为自己夺回时间，静静地与我正在做的事情待在一起。我认为这将是一个很好的挑战。
challenge in delayed gratification, a challenge in uncomfortable stillness and boredom, and just, I want to see if I can do it and I want to see if it's something that will actually help me. I have a feeling that it will, considering every single person who I've ever, I've talked about it with genuinely sounds like they are in a cult. So am I willingly signing up for this cult? Yeah, I think I am and I will report back. But yeah, tell me what you think. Tell me in the comments below if you are also having this strange, dilemma with your phone, whether you're also seeing the appeal of all these people who are leaving technology behind, do we think this is going to become more common and more popular,
这是一个对延迟满足的挑战，一个对令人不安的安静和无聊的挑战，我只想看看自己能不能做到，并想看看这是否真的能帮到我。我有种预感会的，考虑到每一个和我谈过这事的人，听起来都真诚得像加入了邪教。那我是在自愿加入这个邪教吗？是的，我想我是的，我会回来汇报的。不过，是的，告诉我你们的想法。在下面的评论区告诉我，你是否也在经历这种奇怪的手机两难境地，你是否也看到了那些抛弃科技的人的吸引力，我们认为这会变得越来越普遍和受欢迎吗？
especially as people are kind of at their wits end with social media and with technology and with AI and with all these other things? I think so. I personally think that it's going to be like a huge counterculture, counter-revolutionary thing. I'm excited to be a participant, maybe, hopefully let me know your thoughts below and make sure that you are following along wherever you are listening to this episode whether you're on youtube Spotify, Apple podcasts so that you know when we release new episodes maybe even an update episode to this one make sure you yes again leave a comment below and are following us on Instagram at that psychology podcast so that you can let me know your thoughts and also share any future
特别是当人们对社交媒体、对科技、对人工智能以及所有这些其他事情感到忍无可忍的时候？我认为会的。我个人认为这将是一场巨大的反文化、反革命运动。我很兴奋能成为其中的参与者，也许吧，希望如此。请在下方让我知道你们的想法，并确保在你们收听这一集的任何地方都关注我们，无论是在YouTube、Spotify还是苹果播客，这样你们就知道我们什么时候发布新节目，甚至可能是对这一集的更新节目。请务必再次在下方留下评论，并在Instagram上关注我们：@thatpsychologypodcast，这样你们就可以让我知道你们的想法，并分享你们希望我们报道的未来节目的任何建议，关于我们的20多岁、关于文化、关于心理学以及更多内容的任何话题。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一点。放下你那该死的手机。我们很快就会再聊。2%。这就是当自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。
suggestions for episodes you want us to cover any topics about our 20s about culture about psychology, about so much more. And until next time, stay safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. Get off your damn phone. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了精神坚韧度、健康体魄以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。请在IHeartRadio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。即《TWO%》。在《Look Back at it》播客中。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast.
从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利ッシュ（Alex English）。每一集，我们挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并尝试与我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家一起，理解我们是如何度过难关的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈80年代。84年是个疯狂的年份。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
那是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Look Back at it》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·加姆斯（Kear Games）主持的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个空间关乎黑人男性的经历，进行诚实的对话，这些对话在任何地方真的都不安全，但你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套坚固的
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit off? armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the
盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你不是好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要去使用它。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。2023年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你捏造了这个特定的测试两次，欧文斯女士，对吗？我捏造测试了一次。这动用了大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一名同性恋者。迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。
capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian. Michael Mancini.
我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。请在IHeart Radio应用程序、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。
My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《情网难逃》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于受到了惩罚。请在iHeart Radio应用、Apple Podcasts或您收听播客的任何地方收听《情网难逃》播客。这是一个iHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。